thank you very much welcome to my code
about coding kits and screaming carrots
and just make sure in this presentation
I talk about kids in the age from 6 to
12 years and I hope you enjoy it
- churches Cali artists I am 34 years
old I live in Munich and I'm working for
sinner Shradha as a front-end developer
in my spare time I teach coding kids
which is the inspiration for this talk
today I'm also origami addicted
since Takeshi taught it to me in front
of Osaka Castle nearly two years ago in
Japan today unfold nearly every day and
also created a JavaScript project about
virtual origami folding so let's start
and first some nostalgia fun with me as
the coding kit to make sure you have the
proper in the image that's me I'm 10
years old it's 1994 I called this
chapter of my life magazine hoarder
for a reason at the time I love to play
with my Super Nintendo and Sega Game
Gear my favorite place to be
month-by-month is a store with the huge
Shelf of magazines most magazines had
some CDs attached the ones about
computers usually contained applications
trials drivers and patches why because
internet was not available to everyone
and could a University's not at all I
did even on the computer yet I only got
in touch with real computers when my
sister took me to her agency office
there I had the opportunity to think
around with her Mac running the
wonderful OS 9 Photoshop was my favorite
application I created dozens of those
galaxy spirals
let's jump to 1997
the year the year of my first PC
actually I had to wait until Christmas
1997 it's now 3 years since I bought my
first magazine my computer was running
Windows 95 and I had a 4 gigabyte hard
disk this thing had of course no
internet and what does it do with a
brand new computer of course playing
games
it's 1998 and I had showed my computer
day and night my very first game iPod
was played run off from
Westwood studios it was distributed and
forced these and took up half of my disk
space let's hurry to 1999 the year I got
my internet access
I had a 56k modem to connect which was
slower than you then your throttle data
blend on your smartphone today let's
listen to the iconic sound for a quick
flashback
if I get sound
yeah and I still can't believe that the
internet worked back then it was some
random day in April 1999 I was watching
my favorite TV station called NBC Giga
they usually talk about games and
computers all day long this particular
day two guys was showing a brand new
applications for creating animations the
letter read ball bounced around and must
have looked like this and it was
impressed they mentioned the name of the
application but I her to her back for
afternoon classes and I didn't write it
down after school I wanted to search
port while version on all of my magazine
cities but I forgot the name the week
went by quickly it is Saturday which
means getting up as early as possible
and watching serious like saber Rider
kept future or duck tails and around
lunchtime
I watched Giga TV again and I could not
believe it
it was the repeated show from earlier of
the week I was frozen in front of my TV
I hold it my press awaited for the
moment they would tell me the name I
forgot and then they did was on a TV
screen it was called Macromedia flash
for were leased just weeks before and
this moment just now with flash this was
the chances of my whole programming
career flash looked like this there's a
timeline some layers and tools and of
course the stage where things move
around I quickly found a place to code
and soon I was able to program the very
famous you cup menu it's a horizontal
navigation with the illusion of infinity
and it was so good in programming that
thing that I could sell it to agencies
to earn my first money with 15 years it
was amazing time full of amazing
websites what you see here is the portal
from the bow on yes this is a Watson
website and stuff like this drove my
ambition to get me where I am today so
what's my point you are asking well
remember the genesis of my programming
career in front of TV I wish I would
have had some guidance during
so so that more than a single moment in
front of the TV would have guided me to
my career is that the most digital thing
I had in primary school was this later
computer classes
I remember were more like this and
computer classes today are still bad the
hardware if any outdated most teachers
are not educated and the curriculum is
boring I want to make a difference and
change things that's why I'm teaching
kids coding in my spare time and I want
you to know why I'm doing this and that
you can do it too so for the next 20
minutes I will talk about why coding
matters how to teach it and where to
teach it so why does coding for kids
matter at all
let's start something easy we all can
describe to a child how combustion
engine works more or less right we can
even tell how the human body works but
when you press the play button on a
youtube video yeah what would you tell
that kid it's hard for many of us it's
like something was missing in school so
let's fix this for our children by
teaching coding to kids the whole world
is talking like that it's like people
are concerned about the future of our
kids or that we feel that technology
leaves us behind but no matter what the
demand is the same our kids should learn
coding is this justified I'm biased in
this question for obvious reasons so
let's step back and take a look at the
bigger picture we start by looking at a
mechanic and apply the whole coding
discussion onto it and it goes like this
it's sort of like an obsession with
being an auto mechanic there are tons of
cars and there's tons of driving but
they think it's a little silly to go
around saying that everyone should
really learn to be an auto mechanic just
because cars are so essential to the
functioning of our society yeah that
would be silly indeed but what do we do
there's tons of technology and we go
around and tell everybody how important
coding is so are we silly then or
are we just talking about something else
in encoding what if the word coding is
born out of confusion the question is
what do people actually mean with coding
in 1943 cannot Susa built his famous set
free and together with it the very first
programming language called plan
calculate the set free it looked like
this and technology escalated them
pretty quickly with the smartphone you
hold a device that combines everything
will learn in the past 70 years that's a
lot and very complex it makes computer
science not easy to talk about coding on
the other side is easy to trust just
take someone at a keyboard and watch
that person giving commands to a
computer that's coding and the people
understand it if coning is such an easy
word maybe that's why it's mixed up
let's try a theory when people talk
about coding they actually mean
technology and people demand our kids
not to learn coding they actually say
our kids need to learn technology and
the whole coding discussion suddenly
makes sense
it's not about coding anymore it's about
exposure to technology computer science
and programming so kids can understand
the bigger picture and the connecting
lines most of the kids will never be a
coder anyway our children should learn
that smartphones and technology are not
magical that there are limitations
benefits and possibilities from using
them teaching coding still makes sense
it's only one part of understanding
technology but you benefit in many ways
when you learn to code as a coder you
make the transition from being a
consumer to a producer who can tell
stories and create own worlds in the
computer coding stretches your mind and
it creates a thinking which is useful in
all domains the room for creativity is
endless it's like painting and music but
often more accessible and affordable
and speaking of affordable coding gives
you chances computers achieve nowadays
so even poor kids can afford it
diversity the computer just don't
who you are everybody can become a coder
today so I hope I have convinced you by
now why teaching coding metrics so let
me show you some possibilities how to
teach coding I will present you now a
list of my favorite tools I love to use
when teaching it's about tinkering
robots and actually coding let's have a
look at think ring this is all about
playing around with electronics for
example with AD robot this is a toy that
every kid starting with for years can
build himself the parts cost less than
two years if I cut with free legs made
of pens a battery and a rotating motor
when activated the robot will vibrate
and start walking around drawing on the
underlying surface this looks like real
art in the end and it's so much fun for
the kids to watch their robot to be
alive and making Mickey its simplicity
it's just awesome it's basically an
electronic board that pretends to be a
computer keyboard when two connected
objects touch each other they close a
circuit on the makey makey and you
virtually press a defined key on you
keep on your computer and what can you
do with it build a Super Mario
controller find a Mario game that you
can control with the keyboard take some
play-doh which is surprisingly
conductive and design your own game
and you know your own game controller to
move and champ our next tool are robots
many of them can be programmed with the
child-friendly programming language let
me show you some say hello - dot those
are robots with many sensors LEDs and
speakers together they cost around two
hundred years to play with the robots
you can use the app wonder where
everything is about exploring and
adventures you don't create programs but
you solve missions by using commands for
light sound and movement this also an
app where you have more of a coding
experience
this gives the kid a focus on their own
creativity with the robots and what it's
my favorite robot he's based on Arduino
Uno and open source this means you could
theoretically create all parts yourself
and use the software for free you can of
course buy it as a package for 80 euros
and what's so special about it that the
kit will assemble it usually within 20
minutes you can then start an automatic
program use an app or code your own
program when you activate the autonomous
driving mode it will use its ultrasonic
and special line sensor to follow a line
and avoid obstacles in front of it let's
look how coding is being pitched you
usually tackle it in three different
parts analog activity playing games and
dive into the actual coding experience
let's look at the analog activity if you
want to control a robot you have to
behave like a robot first so it's play
the human robot game one kid or you
dresses up as a robot a helmet is
usually enough for delusion but a full
custom like this is never wrong you
explain the kids in the round that they
can only only use five commands to
control the robot forward turn left turn
right backward and stop so let's begin
imagine this task you want the robot to
turn to the right and walk in that
direction so you begin with the turn
right right let's see what happens after
the kids yell that command to the robot
the robot will spin forever and ever and
ever
of course the command was correct but
not exact enough they should have said
turn right for a quarter while spinning
around somebody somebody will hopefully
scream a releasing stuff to the
desperate robot in the end kids really
love that game collaborate and
understand to understand the limits of a
machine they also understand the
requirement of
Zak commands and to put one command of
the number just like in programming you
proud is ready for some more fun
let's play some coding games there's a
movement called
hour of code to do so there are dozens
of one our games and tutorial tutorials
translated in over 45 languages
everybody's encouraged to try it the
games are themed after kids darlings
like Princess Elsa minecraft or Angry
Birds and they teach the principles of
programming while playing I usually pick
a may style game to follow up with the
human robot example this is a Samba
level where zombie has to be guided to
his favorite food a sunflower of course
and commands are given with colorful
blocks and snap to get out like an
apostle you use a simple set of commands
to do so like move forward turn left
turn right
kids will usually place one command
after the other that symbol and it's
working but results in a huge list
they can't even complete the level as
they are forced to use a new clock the
pink one here which is used to repeat
commands I then show them a pattern of
for clocks they can repeat instead of
the huge list forward left forward right
and I point them to the pink repeating
block and success they usually just know
what you do pick the pink loop lock and
replace the repeating pattern inside the
huge list from before is is now a small
and beautiful block of code I love this
moment I explain that this is what a
computer is for the computer should
repeat the boring stuff it is not your
task after an hour the kids should have
should have internalized those block
based commands and they are ready for
scratch to do some real coding scratch
is the most famous tool in kids
programming
it was invented by mr. Reznik at the MIT
Media Lab in 2002 scratch can be used as
an application or online in the web
browser through flash the next version
free is based on HTML
and will be released in August
everything your code can be shared on a
scratch website and remixed by others as
the source code is always accessible
let's have a look inside scratch on the
left you have a stage where everything
will move around and on the right you
see the coding editor that's where you
cut with colorful blocks this is called
plot based programming and very easy to
understand by children and to complete
this section I brought you something
special a screaming carrot which is also
part of the sensational table it's
programmed in scratch and it will make
use of a makey makey so I will switch
over to my application spray if this is
working
yeah I will align myself here so this is
set up I prepared and you will see
momentarily what I've prepared here
because I am going to switch over into
webcam mode so that's me and you should
see now the hardware I've prepared the
people in the front should have problems
recognizing it because the resolution is
a little bit low but I would find my
best explaining it so you can fulfill
the rest of the image so what you can
see here now is first of all a kitchen
knife
made of steel that's important the
mandatory carrot you can see here two
connecting cables they are called
alligator clips and they are titled
because they are looking like an
alligator and you have here
they make you make you I hope you can
see it now it's this board and you can
see some contact points you see some
labeled with space or just the arrow
keys mimicking the ones on your keyboard
and at the bottom is your crown but
which is required to close the circuit
so let's connect all that stuff I will
use the space key at the space contact
point to connect it I will plug it into
the carrot I will use the creme cable to
connect to the grounding bar and I will
plug it into the knife and what happens
now is when I attach the carrot
I will line it here if attach the card
it will flow through the orange cable
into the carrot through the knife back
in and make it make in the makey makey
will tell the computer hate the space
key is pressed and you can do fantastic
stuff with this so I will connect it and
show you what it's doing at the moment
you will see it heavily playing which is
a good sign
yep and if I touch it you should see in
the lower right corner
Faye's keep rest that's boring because I
promise you something even cooler so
let's do a quick live coding session
yeah so that's pretty hot over my
shoulder but I will get there because a
well prepared so this is the part which
is showing the whistle and I will
replace it with the sound I prepared its
code name is Sam sound I will plug it
here and you can read there when space
key is pressed play sound Sam sound
until done so let's see what happens
happening if I'm going back into full
screen mode I will show you the carrot
not it's coming my way life cone is
always failing okay so let's try it
to cut the carrot I mean it's a really
big one
[Applause]
and I promise I will eat that carrot
just to save the moment so let's get
back into the presentation okay
what's left is the question where
everybody could try teaching coding I
want to stress the word everybody you
don't have to be a programmer everybody
can learn coding and everybody can teach
about coding or robots I started
teaching coding to kids in my spare time
exactly one and a half years ago at the
Habad digital workshop they started in
Berlin in 2016 and opened an office in
Munich in 2017
the schedule is about coding with
scratch robotics stop-motion movies and
exploring worlds minecraft if you want
to try it just drop em a mail like I did
you could also host an hour of code
event where you play games like the
zombie game and explain the basics of
programming to interested people you
might even find some hour of code in
your hometown try to join and get in
touch with the organizers and don't
forget your family at home you can start
teaching your own kids and relatives
easily with the tools I have shown you
and you won't believe it but designers
project managers or maybe your clients
are eager to learn coding too they will
have fun and understand you better the
next time you talk about bits and bytes
ok enough about how why and where to
teach coding there's another important
thing we didn't talk about yet what
about me the teacher what do I get
well when did you play with toys for no
reason the last time it's healthy and it
relaxes your mind
it literally entertains to get inside
you and teaching coding makes not only
the kids but you creative you need to
think about what to do with a makey
makey or create coding challenges in
scratch and maybe you will use scratch
for yourself to surprise someone special
on the birthday if you're coda did you
ever try to explain someone for
Reming yes it's very difficult you have
to reflect on the very very basics of
programming again but once you've
mastered this it will help you
throughout your whole mentoring career
and working with kids is fun I always
had an amazing time and I'm still
surprised about all the funny ideas they
have you have a bag full of knowledge
now use it a quick recap of what I've
told you
coding matters because it was never
about coding oddly but it being exposed
to technology computer science and
programming so kids can see the bigger
picture and the connecting lines between
technologies but coding still makes
sense
computers don't care who you are and are
cheap so many can afford it and coding
boosts your creativity and learns are
thinking useful in all domains and you
know how to do it too by building robots
and using a makey makey
to make her a screen for example you
also know that they are robots for kids
robots like dash and dot or am bots that
are easily programmable and finally let
the kids play the human robot game
followed by some zombie mazes to prepare
them for coding and scratch where they
can unleash their creativity and you
know where you can teach to like at the
Ditka table action at the place I
started with locations around Germany or
you decide to host or join an hour of
code event and don't forget you can
always start teaching your family at
home or make your office happy by
teaching people a bit about coding and
there's one last thing I want to tell I
still remember my very first time I
teach kids declawing in their eyes when
they connected the pieces and finally
understood what I teach them this is the
reason I stand in front of you today and
I want you to experience the same and
help some kids finding their way through
technology you can find the slides and
the linked list and at this URL thanks a
lot for listening